Hello, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We are The Slow Mo Guys and today,
we're not in my back garden
where it's nice and bright.
We're in my dark, dingy garage
where we keep our props.
It's unusual for us.
The reason for that is because
we've had a lot of requests
to film an iris constricting when it comes
into a lot of light very suddenly.
You can't do that outside.
And we're gonna film this on a macro lens
a thousand frames a second.
Usually, the macro lenses we've used,
they're slightly bulky and
I think I actually struggled
to get at your eyeball because
of your big old eyebrow.
My Neanderthal brow.
And eye socket.
So we're using this Laowa macro lens,
which is a very odd
shape, but after we take
the lens cap off, it also has LED lighting
and I think with this,
I'll actually be able
to get right up against your ball.
My eyeball.
Oh, God.
As long as you don't poke my eye out.
I'll try not to.
The widest aperture on this lens is an F14
which is actually gonna make it very dark
when we're shooting at a
thousand frames a second,
so it's very good that it's
got a light on the end of it.
Stick it on the camera here.
It's actually longer than the camera.
Well we can either film your eye
or I can give you some sort
of medical examination.
I know which one I'd prefer.
So when sat close it looks
like just a normal lens
except we can go much, much closer.
Down a bit, to your eye. There you go.
Down slightly. Perfect. You're
right in the middle of that.
God, even just my breathing
is rocking me all over the place.
Don't bash your eyeball.
Oh, you can feel your eyelashes.
I mean, honestly this is gonna be
one of the easier videos
for me technically to do
cause all I have to do is
sit in a chair really still.
But at the same time it's not relaxing
cause I'm gonna have this
huge lens shoved in my eyeball
and a bunch of bright lights
turned on immediately.
Yeah.
bloody hell. No big
movements anymore, okay?
Plug in the lense power.
Oh my God that's bright.
The thing is, my heart
beat is moving my eye.
I'm gonna turn it off,
gonna set the frame rate
back to a thousand
and I'm gonna turn the
lights off in here for a bit.
Oooh, that is dark.
You know I got like floaties now.
You got floaties?
Yeah. Don't make me laugh, I'll move.
All right, you ready?
Yeah.
Three, two, one
Ah, oh, that is mental.
I got actually a donut in my eye now.
All I can see is a huge
fat pink and blue donut.
Turn the light on.
Oh, it's completely blue now.
I just got this blue ring in my vision.
Oh, it's really weird.
Was it all right?
Look at it.
I don't think I've ever seen
an eye so open that close.
Oh that's weird.
The muscles haven't started moving yet.
Oh there they go. Now
it's closing. See that?
Yeah. God. Look at the
moisture on my eyeball.
That is mental.
So the focus has changed slightly.
You decided you had enough.
The thing is to me, I was like Ahhhh,
I want it gone.
ooh gross.
What's that right there? What is that?
Oh it's so disgusting. That's madness.
Maybe turn the light a little less bright?
I could do it less bright
and I can maybe half the frame rate.
To 500.
Yeah, I think that might be a good idea.
The thing is my heart beat is moving me.
And you making me laugh
is making me move a bunch.
Oh this is amazing. We're
on the closest I can be.
3, 2, 1
Oh. Phew
Bloody good. Amazing.
That was really good.
So you're all right?
Flipping heck.
Right, this is what's happening, okay.
First of all, that's
outrageous for a start.
Then it's immediately just a
flash of just pure brightness
and then it slowly turns into a donut.
The donut is originally like this
and then it becomes a donut
with a bigger hole in the middle
because my eye is constricting
and I can see more detail of the light
if you know what I mean.
Ready?
Mm hm.
Oh.
Wow. That looks so weird.
It's starting to move.
There's actually a small delay.
I wonder, we could probably
count that delay by the frames.
And you see all these creases,
they're actually really soft and fibrous.
When your eye is completely
dilated they change shape.
Oh, those holes on the outside of my eye
were so much fatter and
bigger, and now they're tall.
Oval.
Yeah.
Isn't that weird. It
drags the entire pattern
and you an actually see the layers.
But you can very clearly here
see what is on top and what
is underneath of your iris.
So weird. And my iris
isn't perfectly circular.
See there's little bits on the outside
that are coming around.
It's true.
It is crazy to think
that every single thing
you've ever seen was through that hole.
Well, half of it.
This is the closest to
the window to the soul
you can possibly be.
You're basically trying
to look into my soul here.
I reckon I can do this one thing
where I move my iris really
quickly from side to side.
Oh, you shake your eyeball?
Yeah, I shake my eyeball
slightly. Yeah, like that.
Oh God.
You went cross-eyed.
I can't do it quite as big as that
but I think cause we're so close
you should be able to
see a bit of shakage.
And when I was filming my eye
and I was moving my eye
around, I could see,
because the iris is a
muscle and there's liquid,
it was jostling.
So I wonder if when your eye vibrates,
would it be sloshy almost.
Weird.
Yeah, we'll find out.
That was it?
Yeah.
Oh, didn't know you did it.
Oh yeah, I was doing it.
Oh, I'm salsa dancing my eye.
I had no idea it was that liquidy.
Oh my God. Do you see that?
So those areas of your
eye where there's craters,
they're loose.
I didn't know that.
They almost have their own
eyelids when you do that.
They do. Look how the
fibers are closing in
and moving about. Do you see that?
Looks like just like a
fat butt jiggling around.
So gelatinous. It is like jelly.
It's almost like a weave,
like each one is a string.
I think that's what it is.
That's the best way to describe it.
It jiggles.
It looks like spaghetti.
Looks like overcooked
spaghetti moving around.
Well that was some
graphic looking footage.
I might not be able to tell.
How many fingers am I holding up?
One donut.
That's about right.
Yeah. God.
I'll tell you what though,
I don't think I can ever in the future
use iris recognition software
cause everyone has the
perfect image of my eyeball.
Yeah. An iris scan does not work.
You got the least secure
iris now on the planet.
And I've already filmed my
eye so we're both toast.
Well, hopefully you enjoyed that video
or you were grossed out by it.
I feel like either one
is a victory for us.
Please feel free to
subscribe to the Slo Mo Guys
and check back in a little
bit for the next video
when hopefully Dan will
be able to see again.
Your life's in my hands now.
I've gotta drive home with you in the